welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or can sign up for free and
get the bonus companion worksheets that
go along with each video by checking the
link down in the description below
alright today is day 29 and we're gonna
learn how to be better speakers most
leaders most businesspeople
most entrepreneurs most human beings
have never learned to be masterful
communicators and the very nature of
influence and impact which is the
leaders job is communication I mean in
school were you given a communication
course very few people have been taught
that in your personal relationships have
you read books on communication well
that leads to I mean in in an intimate
relationship or even just with a friend
it's the little miscommunications that
overtime stack into loss in your
intimate relationships it's the little
conversations that you could have had in
five minutes if you have the tools to
communicate and the awareness to speak
so literally you could release the anger
and build understanding and speak out
your needs and feel the need to be heard
all those little things if you had
learned how to do that over and done it
in five minutes with your intimate
partner you might not have lost the
relationship and in your professional
life learning to communicate inspires
your teammates you know if you look at
the great leaders of humanity the Nelson
Mandela is the mother Teresa for Martin
Luther King Junior's the john f
kennedy's if you look at the great
business builders Steve Jobs great
example right he would be on the stage
at the product launch and then that
favorite line one more thing and that's
when he would reveal the latest piece of
technology that would create industry
dominance when Steve Jobs was at Apple
well he was a masterful communicator and
Bud Tribble over at Apple called it his
reality distortion field Steve Jobs was
a master salesman he knew exactly what
to say to get people to believe in the
impossible to allow their I can't to be
less valuable than their I camps second
element in terms of how legendary
leaders speak is their masterful
listeners another gargantuan competitive
advantage how the great leaders do it is
they're just so comfortable in their own
skin they're if they've worked on their
ego so much they've turned down the
volume most people's idea of listening
is waiting until the other person has
finished talking so they can start their
own monologue I can't tell you how many
times I'll have a walk with someone I
love walking meetings one-hour walks I
learned it from Steve Jobs and through
the entire walk there just sharing their
story and they're sharing where they're
at and they're sharing their
frustrations and they're sharing their
insecurities and they haven't asked me a
single question and I'm happy to help
I'm happy to listen someone asked me the
other night
oh you know when that happens what do
you do and I say you know what most
people have a deep need to be heard and
someone who talks and talks and talks
and talks is generally a child who had
parents who didn't give them a lot of
time and they didn't give him a lot of
attention and they certainly didn't give
them very much listening and so adults
are nothing more than deteriorated
children and adults are often children
in grown-up bodies and I see that and I
simply am very happy to be a listening
ear for them I'm very happy to give them
the listening they are longing for and I
just feel in that hour
I can be an instrument of service to
them and helpful to them by listing
point I'm trying to help you calibrate
and hardwire in is a daily protocol be
one of the rare air whew one of the
have 5% leaders on the planet who really
have dialed in to listening not from
your head but from your heart
listening at a cellular level and here's
the thing when you do that for your team
they grow bigger right in front of you
and the real job of a leader is to grow
people real job of a leader is to build
more leaders real job of a leader is to
leave a blazing trail of epic producers
behind you that's when you know that
you're leading versus following so get
seriously genius at listening rarely are
we instant experts you may have a
particular gift or affinity toward
something but you still get better you
know people would pay me high
compliments when I started speaking and
then people who've seen me a year or two
later say that I'm even better and I
feel it why is that because you you you
learn more you know I think that hubris
is dangerous I think to think that
you're an expert in anything is a
foolish pursuit you're never you're
never as good as you could be there's
always room for improvement
there's always room to get better you
don't that does mean you have to listen
to all the advice just you know not
necessarily does everybody know best but
but to believe that you can be better
and to believe that you can offer more
is a constant pursuit you know I used to
think being a public speaker meant being
poised and presenting in a way that was
compelling and speaking at the right
pace and that's that's a part of it
but but I have been taking more risks
lately doing things that are very
unstructured and very uncomfortable and
I will now do like if I have an hour to
speak I'd rather speak for 20 minutes
and do 40 minutes worth of questions and
who knows how that's gonna go and that
to me is the best and so I'm a better
speaker because now I'm way more open to
the unknown where a few years ago that
that would have scared me Nelson Mandela
is a particularly special case study in
the leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depend
the nation you go to we have different
opinions about other personalities but
Nelson Mandela across the world is
universally regarded as a great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief and he was asked one day how did
you learn to be a great leader and he
responded that he would go with his
father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things when his father
would meet with other elders one they
would always sit in a circle and to his
father was always the last to speak you
will be told your whole life that you
need to learn to listen I would say that
you need to learn to be the last to
speak I see it in boardrooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what I
think but I'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself
until everyone has spoken does two
things one it gives everybody else the
feeling that they have been heard it
give me gives everyone else the ability
to feel that they have contributed and
two you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion the skill is really
to keep your opinions to yourself if you
agree with somebody don't nod yes if you
disagree with somebody don't nod no
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying and at the end
you will get your turn it sounds easy
it's not practice being the last to
speak that's what Nelson Mandela did
there's something that always works to
get rapport and that's something called
matching and mirroring the person who
pointed out was Milton Erickson he
understood that you have both a
conscious mind and a subconscious mind
and he knew the subconscious is more
powerful its main part that makes your
heart beat a hundred thousand times a
day without him to think about and he
began to notice something about human
beings that when human beings got
together if they got in rapport a
relationship of responsiveness they
became like each other in a variety of
ways what he called they mirror at each
other here's the basis of it people like
people who are like whom themselves and
people don't like people who are not
like themselves to be more specific
rightness now people like people who are
like themselves or who are like how they
would like to be now if you want to be
effective then mirroring is so easy we
do it naturally but here's the problem
most people wait till they have enough
words in common then then they put the
voice in common in the body in common
but words only seven percent they don't
work all the time breathing breathing is
very powerful one of the most powerful
if you breathe that the exact same pace
as another person you will feel what
they are feeling period but you got to
be in for the same location the same
tempo and breathing is magnificent
because it really hooks you to this
person you looked a mirror everything
someone does that rapport it's not like
they lift their leg you lift your leg
they lean forward you lean forward they
sit back they you sit back you don't
have to do that although believe it or
not you can do a lot and people not even
notice but for example you get rapport
just with the leg position and maybe the
tone of voice
because physiology is 55% of
communication if you're sitting there
let's say let's say you cross your leg
like this can I cross my leg like this
while we're talking yes or no
it'll feel comfortable to you so you
start bouncing your foot like this back
and forth can i bounce my foot same
tempo if I do you'll feel totally
connected to me enthusiasm I mean look
at the video of me coming out on stage
watch me interact with the audience so
watch me on any of my youtube videos
watch listen to my podcasts hpx podcast
it's like everything that I believe
about HP X which stands for the high
performance experience is about the
enthusiasm and zest we must have for
life or that we must generate and create
and so I'm just enthusiastic on stage
even if I'm scared even I'm worried if
I'm concerned and I
certainly walking out in front of
thousands of people wasn't my original
Jam I mean I I was that person who was
not good at that did not have skill that
and did not want to do that but the
reason that I became a good communicator
and challenged myself to become a good
communicator was because I realized if I
couldn't communicate well I couldn't
make a good difference if you don't
teach yourself train yourself put
yourself in those situations where you
become a better speaker of a better
communicator a better leader and how are
you ever gonna change the world how are
you ever gonna do something that you
feel is like significant and important
so I trained myself to do that so I make
sure that I'm enthusiastic for my topic
and my mission and my purpose when I go
out on that stage
even if inside I feel anxiety I feel
like I don't know if I'm gonna do a good
job those things listen when your fear
becomes secondary to your enthusiasm for
your purpose that's when everything
changes that was a life truthfully if
you're gonna speak about something you
need to know a lot about it you need to
know three or four times as much as
you're gonna speak about at minimum so
first of all you have to do your
background research you have to have
multiple stories at hand that you can
use to illustrate your point and you
have to have a point you have to
organize what you're talking about
around a problem so before I go on stage
to speak on my tour I always sit for
half an hour some of which involves
usually about five minutes of anxiety
and I think okay there's a problem I'm
trying to address tonight a central
problem or a theme what is it might be
courage it might be responsibility it
might be meaning I think and that serves
as an organizing principle so that would
be the point and then basically I
organize say a dozen stories around that
and I can kind of arrange them in it as
a journey and it's a journey that
circles the main point and so I'm trying
to explore it to say what I think about
courage let's say but to take what I'm
thinking farther than I've taken it
already and so that I can plot out you
know little five-minute stories that I
have that are associated with courage
and then I can talk to the audience and
I would say talk about what you know use
your personal experience because that's
not something that you're actually a
master of you can bring in other
material but it has to be tied to the
real world through your own experience
otherwise it's not real it's also very
good to speak directly to the audience
to the individuals in the audience
because I'm always looking at a single
person one after another and focusing on
them and talking to them just like you'd
have a conversation with someone and
that way I can see if they're following
along and I'm always listening to the
what I really like to hear from the
audience is no noise at all silence
because if the audience especially you
know if it's a couple hundred or a
couple of thousand people if the
audience is dead silent then I know that
I'm on the right track you're telling
stories so every fact that you relate or
every set of facts has to be tied to a
story there has to be a meaningful
output which is something like why is it
important to your life that you know
this fact how is it related to how
you're going to conduct yourself moving
forward or how are you going to see the
world so because that's kind of the
essence of meaning how does this fact
change the way you perceive the world or
act in the world that's the meaning of
the fact and facts without meaning are
dull so you need to know that you need
to tell the truth that's for sure and
and and I mean for me my talks are
really they're an attempt to explore a
set of ideas in the most truthful way
that I can manage and that's also an
adventure because letting yourself speak
freely about a topic you don't always
know where it's gonna go and so but that
also hooks in the audience because
they're not there along for the ride
right and there's a risk that risk is
you might forget where you are you might
lose the thread you might say something
you regret you might get confused and
it's this the talk should be a process
of exploration like a journey that
you're taking the audience along on it's
the same when you're reading a novel
like a great novel isn't exactly plotted
out from beginning to end to begin with
the author is taking himself or herself
and you on an intellectual adventure
through the through the character
development and the characters have to
be allowed to live and to express
themselves and the novel needs to unfold
it's like a colloquy between the
conscious mind and the unconscious
source of inspiration and the novel is
actually a journey through a
characterological
landscape and the author shouldn't know
where he or she's gonna end up at the
beginning same with an artist and who's
writing a song or a piece of music or a
piece of visual art there has to be play
and explore
along the way and so you also don't want
to deliver an over prepared talk in my
estimation or at least that's not how I
do it you want to have a theme you want
to have a body of knowledge from which
you can draw on and then you want to be
actively exploring the idea in front of
the audience and that's very gripping
for everyone including you and so and
you should learn something from the talk
it's an opportunity to think on your
feet and anyways that's my style of
lecturing it's it's a trapeze act
without a safety net
I would say and that's part of what
makes it gripping is that there's a high
probability of failure and I would say
with any performance that's going to be
gripping that on the edge of the seat
gripping there has to be a high
probability of failure and that's why I
don't speak with notes if you speak with
notes which you might have to if you're
a beginning speaker then you cannot fail
because you can always read the notes
and so there's a there's a net you'll
fall in the net but you won't die but
you'll never do anything spectacular so
that's the thing is if you're gonna do
something spectacular you have to take
the risk and if you're gonna take the
risk you have to think on your feet
there are certain commonalities to all
human beings right when it comes to
rapport building it to report both in a
business setting and a personal setting
but it really boils down to two things
number one that you care yes that in
business you're not just there to make a
sale to earn a commission you actually
care about the person and you want them
to get the outcome they're looking for
that's number one and number two is that
um just like you we and not like
everything you like I like that's
disingenuous [ __ ] right like you
know you see a fish roll oh my god you
like to fish out too you know like
Michael Scott back off that's ridiculous
right I'm talking about something very
different talking about that you speak
at the same general pace they do you
hope that when they answer a question
like AHA yup mm got the interest that
you say yup wait I get it we're on the
same page and it's very it's almost
below the surface because here's the
thing imagine you know you just meet a
Salesman you're
a prospect right and the salesman looks
at you and says you know I really care
about you and you can't you want to make
it no warrant see in the beginning
there's no words you can say to say I
care about you all the time of course
you give great service you have a
relation yes you can tell us what I care
and I've proved that but in an initial
contact
that's so disingenuous so how do you
will get that across through tonality
and body language that's how you do it
never make a point without a story and
never tell a story without a point
that's number one that's team because
stories can be used to travel to
people's lives yeah not just incurred
appoints but it creates a significant
emotional event and that's how human
behaviors transform we have emotionally
an emotional memory the next thing in
and speaking there is some fear and that
fear is always there I never assumed
that I know where that audience going to
believe each audience they have their
own personality and each audience their
audience inside of each audience that's
separated by age by race by income by
education the other thing that's crucial
in speaking is that as you speak and as
you look at the audience always take the
time to find out who they are and all
thy getting get understanding so I have
a needs assessment that I set out and I
ask some questions you know what are the
things that you want this audience to
walk away with what are the things that
you've done things that that's stressing
you out what's the unspoken conversation
so I sent out this needs assessment I
talked with a CEO I do research to find
out their mission statement I talked the
marketing director and then I interview
the top performers if it's of sales
organization I talked to the top
performers and then the next step I
interview people in the audience if you
were in my position what are the things
that people in the audience need to hear
if you were in my position that you
would suggest I asked them individually
these five people and then when I'm on
stage I integrate that I marry that to
navigate an experience
said Oliver Wendell Holmes said that
once a man a woman's mind has been
expanded with an idea concept or
experience it could never be satisfied -
going back to where it was so when you
bring all those elements in there with
humor with quotes statistics and stories
you are able to create special moments
that can transform that audience the
other thing when you tell a story don't
just tell the story experience the story
and the audience will go there when you
see the story yeah it's got to be the
story the embodiment of the story so
that the audience as a result of hearing
it that they can't rest that you start
showing up in their dreams my first time
I talked I literally went up and blanked
out like I literally could not think I
could not see the card how I fixed it
speaking was over time but I'll give you
a couple of key things on speaking for
everybody one I had to I had to figure
out you know what someone said because
you love baseball
you don't stutter when you talk about
baseball you don't get insecure I go
well I love that and I believed in it
they're like oh you don't you know you
talk about your kids you're great I
thought oh there's a correlation here
between me actually saying what I
believe and what I'm passionate about
and my ability to communicate it and so
that now my first layer is always I must
be passionate about it and I must
believe it and I'm never doing an
impression of another person so I always
come from a place of saying what I
really believe because you can't
transfer to somebody that which you
don't experience yourself I can give you
passion I can give you energy I can give
you my belief if I'm experiencing it
binkey as a speaker I'll give everybody
stop trying to convince everybody of
what you're saying that's not the
threshold to being a good communicator
people do not need to believe what
you're saying they need to believe you
believe what you're saying and as long
as they believe you believe what you're
saying you're an effective speaker I
stop trying to get people to believe me
there's a neediness there's a
salesmanship to that I stopped that it's
a subtle difference I just want you to
believe I believe it
that's influence influences you believe
I believe it what I'm about to tell you
to do is terrifying and most of us spend
our entire lives trying to avoid it but
like a pap smear it's over fast and it
really works
I just did it did you catch it if not
and you missed it here it goes again
that was a live demonstration of the
three-second I a P the intentional
awkward pause now why on God's green
earth would you ever want to do that
I'll tell you because being a really
really good listener is one of the most
underrated secrets to success it's
crucial if you want to be more
charismatic more persuasive and a better
negotiator Plus really listening to
someone and having them feel truly heard
is one of the biggest gifts you could
ever give the problem is most of us suck
at listening and we don't even know it
we're always interrupting others with
our brilliant ideas and our feedback and
most often it's the whoa Maya that is so
true I'm always interrupting people as I
was saying it's often the way that we
suck the most now I'm probably one of
the worst offenders out there but I am
consistently working on this and I have
to say the ia P is a lifesaver not so
long ago I used it with my stepson Zane
and had an unbelievable result so Zane
was home on Christmas break from college
and he invited me to go for cappuccino
slow a little back story here in the ten
years plus that we've been in each
other's lives he had never really asked
me for a life advice so we get to this
place Cafe Minerva and were hanging out
and Zane starts to tell me all about his
life and what he might want to do with
it he's very very involved with music
he's involved in acting and all these
creative things so basically he's asking
me for the kind of advice that I give
for a living
so you could imagine every single part
of me just wanted to jump in and tell
him what to do and tell him what I think
and yadda yadda yadda but I practiced
the I ap and I just sat there and I
zipped it now every time I did this and
I just shut up it was amazing because he
would just reveal more and more insights
he'd find new things to talk about he'd
find his own insights that were way
better than anything I could have told
him it was really really amazing now I
have to be honest my body was literally
uncomfortable being silent
so every time he would come to an end of
a sentence I would sit and see if there
is more and it was absolutely awesome by
the end of three hours we had the most
beautiful conversation and we left that
cafe feeling more connected and more
intimate than I think we've ever felt so
just a little story to show that it
really really works I used to get
nervous
when I walk up to the stage when all I
could focus on it's me I was so
concerned about what people think what
do I do I do I sound professional would
they understand my accent
make me sure I I cover every point I
want to cover am i telling that story
perfectly
do I sound smart do I look good
whenever you are in front of an audience
and you focus on yourself me me me me me
me me how people perceive you you will
get nervous because you are afraid of
being judged when I shift the focus from
do I sound smart do I look good do I
sound good when I just forget all that
throw that out the window and I 100%
focus on my audience how could I change
their life how can i impact them how can
I make sure they walk away with value
the minute I do that not focusing on
myself or focusing on them the
nervousness disappears it's gone very
very simple because it's all about them
it is my hand in my pocket and my not
not you know standing in the right space
am i walking back and forth am i doing
the right gesture
forget all that when you forget order
you can connect and when you connect
with the audience you're not nervous
because you can all you care it's about
them you don't care about how you look
anymore you don't care if you sound so
smart no you just focus on them no more
their business sometime when I get asked
to speak for three hours and they want
to do Q&A that's a different talk than
it is from an hour to just give a
presentation than it is from hey can you
give a 10 minute talk here then a five
minute talk if I'm asked to talk five
minutes on TV or on whatever it is that
I'm speaking for five minutes
I'm here's a point here's a story Donna
let me tell you bout what's going on
over here
here's the conditions that we're looking
at right now that I thought that uh
here's what I think we need to consider
change into and here's what I believe
will be the solution let me tell you why
I believe this I remember was 1992 and
bomb story okay story so get into your
story when you want it to make your
point tell story somebody who is very
good at making stories and figuring out
ways for me to take a metaphor or an
analogy that I can excited M X that
makes sense I get it I got it I respond
to that and most people respond to that
as well
if you're telling your story now I've
got a really special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best live 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just watch
a video you have to do something about
it so pull out your worksheets and if
you don't have the worksheets you can
get them for free using the link in the
description below here we go question
number one
how will you practice building rapport
this week number two how will you
practice speaking this week and number
three how will you practice telling
great stories this week and if you're
doing the best life 30 challenge with me
I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag best live 30 down in the
comments below
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have and I think a lot of businesses
fail because the entrepreneur cannot
communicate well and if they even are
sharing their ideas they are not
convincing enough and so a lot of great
ideas die you could have the next
greatest idea that can change the world
that's sitting up here but because you
can't articulate it because you can't
share it because you can't communicate
it well and because you're not
convincing enough to the people around
you it will never take off the idea will
die within you and I hate that I hate
that because building a business getting
the thing that's out here out into the
world is greater than one person no
matter how much of a genius you are to
build a business you need a team you
need a team of people to help you go far
and you also need to convince the media
and customers and partners and suppliers
of what you have is amazing if you are
the only one who thinks that your idea
is amazing and you can't communicate or
convince anybody else of that then
you're done then that idea dies within
you and I think unfortunately
that's a lot of entrepreneurs so Jordan
has three of his tips I'm gonna give you
three of mine on how to be a convincing
communicator step number one is have a
powerful opinion you have an opinion
what is it that you are trying to say
make it mean something to yourself and
to me and make that the first sentence
of every piece of content that you make
if you're doing a video that's your
first sentence you're doing an Instagram
post put it in there you're doing a
LinkedIn post an email a newsletter like
put it in there you lead with your
powerful opinion on what is wrong with
the world
or what your viewpoint on XYZ topic is
make it mean something to me
make me care so if I'm talking about
communication how important it is for
entrepreneurs a powerful opinion would
be something like you need to learn how
to communicate in your business or you
will never get that idea that's in your
head out into the world and your idea
will die inside you that's an opinion
where lots of people might say something
like so if you want to learn how to
build a successful business and maybe
take your idea to the next level
I think maybe you should focus on trying
to improve how you speak and communicate
like it's so long it has lots of filler
words you use words like maybe and
potentially and someday and one day and
I wish and we instead of I like
affirmative stop worrying about what
people's reactions are gonna be and
speak your truth always lead with a
powerful opinion tip number two is
emotional commitment this is where a lot
of entrepreneurs really fall down you've
got your pals in a pen you know what you
stand for you know what you're trying to
communicate but when you get in front of
a camera or when you get down to writing
it doesn't sway people it's not
emotional enough you could be saying all
the best words when you get in front of
a camera to make a video but because you
are talking in a very boring very non
exciting manner and because you're so
worried about saying the perfect words
that you are memorizing something or you
are looking at your script or trying to
read from a teleprompter
nobody is going to care or listen to you
you need to have emotional commitment
you need to feel the thing and how
important it is while you are saying it
for me I'm envisioning all of you I'm
envisioning all the entrepreneurs that
I've worked with who have these amazing
ideas and they never get them out
because they can't communicate and even
though I'm sitting here in an office by
myself and there's nobody around to
actually connect with I'm just talking
to a camera I'm trying to channel you
I'm trying to channel all the people
that I've connected with and seen and I
want to make sure that your business
does well and communicating is so
important as part of that which is why
I'm doing this video and hopefully the
care the love the energy comes through
in the content that I make and so sales
and convincing people not enough against
what they want but in a positive way
like this is something that you guys can
get together on is about the energy
transfer you are not just selling a
concept or an idea you are transferring
energy whoever is more confident wins
whoever is more convincing wins and it's
usually from whoever believes in their
thing more if you absolutely believe in
your thing and that this is right and
it's for them when they need to do this
thing because it's in their best
interest not because they're just trying
to sell something down their throat but
you really really really really care and
if they feel that care as opposed to
just words that you're saying that's how
you bring them on board it's great to
have the best words but more important
is the emotional commitment that you
have behind them so the best test with
any of this is watch back some of your
content and watch back your videos read
your newsletters see the copy on your
website look at the story that you wrote
about yourself and why you started this
business does it get you excited it's
like boom boom boom boom boom boom like
yes
that's right that's why I do this thing
or do you watch it and you get bored if
you get bored and it doesn't get your
heart beating and do it again do it
again and do it again and do it again
and do it
you will be one of your best critics you
will be one of your harshest critics and
so we know if you look over your content
and get to the point where you say wow
yeah
I'm really proud of that that's when you
start to win and tip number three is
raise the stakes just make it more
important if you want to move people so
often we're focused just on the tactics
the strategies here's the five things
that you need to do and people say yeah
yeah yeah great I love those the five
things awesome they write them down and
then they never do anything about it you
need to raise the stakes you have to
make it more important you have to make
me feel the pressure that if I don't do
this thing that you want me to do
terrible things will happen right so if
I talk about how important communication
is me just saying communication is
really important as an entrepreneur here
are the three ways to do it it's not as
powerful as communication is one of the
most important skills that entrepreneurs
need to have because if you don't learn
how to communicate your idea and get it
out there that idea will die inside you
and your mission will never be realized
and listen that paints a dark picture
that's going to an extreme and the idea
is not to have hyperbole and make things
bigger than they are but that's a real
case for tons of entrepreneurs that if
they do not learn how to communicate
properly their ideas will never get out
there and their idea will die inside
them and so your goal if you want to
move people is to make them realize how
big this thing is for them if they don't
take action you're the expert you know
where the road is going you see their
future if they continue down that path
they don't see that future they don't
understand it it's your job to help them
see where this current path of action is
gonna lead them and if they make the
tweak they make the change to take your
recommendations where it could go raise
the stakes make it more important make
them feel that it's more important and
it actually starts with you feeling that
this message is insanely
if you want to join the best life 30
challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to be a better speaker check the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you there